quand on parle de tourisme le commun des
mortels en temps avant tout plage
cocotiers vacances or quand on parle de
tourisme d'affaires on est vraiment dans
un cadre professionnel dont il ya une
notion de voyage qui intervient certes
mais c'est une loyale en émotions qui
est complètement lié à un objectif
business donc on ne fait pas du tourisme
d'affaires pour aller s'amuser on fait
du tourisme d'affaires pour aller
développer son activité tisser des liens
avec des partenaires découvrir de
nouveaux marchés donc autant d'éléments
qui n'ont pas grand chose à voir avec du
ludique le point en fait qui est
apparent aujourd'hui c'est que il est
naturel de parler de manière
complètement convergentes d'événementiel
et de tourisme d'affaires parce qu'il
est vrai que quand on fait on se déplace
pour raisons professionnelles
on cherche aussi à animer le l'ensemble
du séjour et du parcours de visites
auxquelles vont avoir droit les
différents participants est aujourd'hui
en fait ce phénomène d'animation va
passer par le numérique
vous me posez la question de savoir si
notre quotidien intégrer le numérique et
dans quelle mesure il va falloir faire
écho à cette nécessité
ce que je disais mon a montré de la
préparation de ces conférences et que le
numérique est une réalité quotidienne
qu'on soit d'ailleurs professionnels ou
particuliers
donc aujourd'hui exister de manière
pertinente dont la société telle qu'elle
se profile et en comprendre les ressorts
demandes de toutes les façons de se
saisir de l'opportunité du numérique
qu'on soit dans le tourisme d'affaires
où qu'on soit un individu lambda
ce que je constate c'est que le
martiniquais lui a complètement intégré
les usages du numérique est en fait une
utilisation intensive quotidienne
la question qui peut se poser après
c'est qu'en est il des acteurs
économiques
est ce que justement les entreprises
martiniquaises ont pris la pleine mesure
de cette réalité la haye ont fait le
nécessaire pour être aussi présente que
le sont les martiniquais sur les sur les
réseaux et des usages numériques
quand je regarde la caraïbe au sens
large
il ya un constat qui n'est pas de moi
qui en fait de l'organisation mondiale
du tourisme qui dit que la caraïbe est
la deuxième destination touristique au
monde
après l'europe sauf que quand on regarde
cette deuxième d'inspiration on se rend
compte que la martinique est pas
forcément au centre du jeu alors je
m'explique
on a en fait des chiffres récents sur
les performances du tourisme en
martinique en 2017 qui sont extrêmement
favorables avec des seuils historiques
qui ont été franches et le million de
visiteurs si je ne trompe pas or dans le
même temps on se rend compte que cette
surperformance martiniquaise est
concomitante d'un problème de sous
performance sur des géographique
normalement sont historiquement beaucoup
plus dynamiques en tourisme aujourd'hui
d'autres géographies se sont organisés
pour être plus attractif que la
martinique
un point pour éclairer ce point de vue
en recherchant le justement quels
étaient les destinations qui attire
attirer les personnes à haut pouvoir
d'achat et les touristes d'affaires dans
les caraïbes
je me suis rendu compte que la
martinique n'étaient pas identifiés dans
les seize destinations les plus
attractives de la région donc je me dis
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que le tourisme
d'affaires naturellement quand il veut
organiser en de ses voyages d'affaires
équivalent et dans les caraïbes
comme c'est bien souvent le cas il va
penser à un autre destination que la
martinique
maintenant la vraie question qui se pose
la martinique veut-elle faire partie de
ce jeu là estime t elle que
effectivement il y a probablement un
facteur un vecteur de développement dans
le tourisme d'affaires qui serait
dommage de ne pas en fait saisir au vol